uh
[Music]
actually it's not second hour last 30
minutes we went a little
long we went a little long the first
hour
so without further ado i think what we
need to see is you know the fighter
and the uh kid is back he has a new
co-host is it
yeah he has new co-hosts swear to god
it's called the literal child it's
called the fire one
it's called the fighter and the kids
with a z
so this is the new show but it's still
titled the fighter in the kid
right because they don't want to change
rss they don't want to lose their
[ __ ] they don't want to lose their
[ __ ] clicker
and sponsorships and stuff like that
yeah
wake up early in the morning press play
and let's get it in cause we rocking
with the fighter and he rolling with the
kids
uh something i want to point out the
fighter and the kids numbers
are not the same as the numbers you're
not getting with uh
no i mean look you say whatever you want
about catelyn and chob they're both
douche bags but they built a following
of course they built a following like
because look joe joe rogan can give
anyone a show they don't all he does
well i know but they don't all work out
and not everybody gets
gets a thing you say whatever you want
about those two but they did click
and they were friends and they got along
and they did a show that
you know even look i will say this even
if your show isn't that great
if two people get along and they have
chemistry and they're having a good time
you will have a good time if you're
watching two guys having a good time
this this whole thing and by the way i
will say this i think callan
is probably doing better with sam
tripoli right now oh yeah
because they're having fun and doing the
show and they know each other and it's
like
you know whatever brendan schaab's just
like yo i don't know b
just bring in a bunch of young black
guys so i look cool
that's his whole gimmick the problem is
when you bring a couple of young black
guys in it makes you look like even
more of a nerd when you're the white guy
and also what's with this new thing now
where black guys are ironically wearing
band shirts from when i was in high
school like
like that's a shirt i would buy because
i'd be like i loved rancid in high
school but like
what what is this falcon chappelle lacy
uh oh never mind he sounds like a black
guy that probably like granted
who are these guys black guys
no i know they're black guys but like
who are they cool black guys
but i think that's the only location the
one in the mall but you [ __ ] no no
no no so wait their set now is
a 50s diner they didn't even use the
same set they're in a 50s diner set now
so is this the can we just have music in
the background it's like
boom boom boom boom have some chick on
like
so what can i get for you love what can
i get darling
it's it's this is this is what they do
now
the [ __ ] earth angel playing in the
background
it's on melrose i haven't been there oh
that probably is that's not a change
dip in his mouth it's like a sneaker
release
yes yeah this lines for that right now
probably nothing more flowers a nice a
thick bratwurst
so he was like this is great because
like this recreates what it feels like
to be at a black movie theater
it's awesome i'm excited at a baseball
game you getting a hot dog oh
a dodger dog all day dodging relish
little mustard
diced onions sauerkraut that's your
trash i know
what do you do at the baseball game why
what do i do to the baseball game
wish i bought tickets to the basketball
game
we had different answers you said he
watched videos
yeah we know what you said this is this
dynamic already is
is breathtaking i'm blown away by it
hey cousin you know that sound you've
been looking for well here it is and it
sucks
no one's going to be like focus on the
game
you go because somebody it's your cousin
marvin rogan
marvin
and also does brennan shop have mouth
cancer or is he just dipping now
i guess you guys aren't ready for this
but your kids are going to hate it
[Laughter]
what are the ratio oh no that's not bad
you know what
you you might not be ready for that but
uh your kids are gonna well no your kids
are gonna have bell's balls yes
you know what brandon shop talk like
yeah bell's palsy before it was cool
that's
you know what back to the future is not
such a bad idea now somebody build me a
time traveling delorean i don't want to
be here anymore i want to go back to
1955
and then go no this is fine oh are you
here to stop something bad from
happening
no well yeah listen people we should
probably start getting out of here now
while we have a chance
they do they've got a hundred thousand
the only the only i've only been to one
baseball game it was in 2006 it was uh
the diamond
diamond diamond blacks diamondbacks play
uh
san francisco and it was uh also why why
is uh brandon schaub dressed like steven
regal when he hit the man's man gimmick
yeah kind of he looks like one that he
looks like when doink the clown left
went to wcw and they made him big josh
but i said this before brennan chop
dresses like the way the mom dresses the
kid of a dad who left
yeah he dr well he dresses like um
like what what an la mexican would dress
like if he wanted to
be stylish oh okay yeah i like like yeah
look at me man
he's like laughs yeah it was like his
last well that's that's really what
you're going yeah brendan
looks like he should be standing in a
home depot parking lot waiting for work
okay i'm skipping ahead a bit 70 years
old
and severely out of shape well yeah
that's how i feel about drew brees but
again
we is it a sports show i'm skipping
ahead something like that uh
i want one on my thigh i want a full i
want like a sleeve on my left leg
you know what the worst part about this
is brennan is still doing the
the same thing he would do if brian
callum was there which is like setting
them up
right like yeah i want to get like a
tattoo of a dragon with a giant penis
on the tip of my penis like and then it
would be 20 minutes of calen calling him
which is at least fun like again i'm not
saying i was a big fan of fighter and
the kid
but at least you had two friends where
you'd be like oh no that's
dude you're like no that's not yeah i
think it's cool nah man it's
when they bust each other's balls but
like everything's i've already witnessed
this three times as you've been skimming
through this
where brandon shaw's like yeah dog like
you know
i'm thinking of getting a tattoo of like
a penis on my ass cheek and the white
black guys are like
a word yeah that's dope well and it's
like they're not
giving them nothing the original title
of the show was fighter and the kids
whose dad left to get to get cigarettes
came back but they couldn't fit it so
they just did this
the fighter and the fatherless kids you
know what i want to hear i want to hear
like a door unlock and go hey i told you
not to come with a steiner [ __ ] lead
dude yeah what you going to get i don't
know i don't know
get the rock on you they get the rock on
though
does he have dip in his mouth yes that's
what i just asked earlier
i asked earlier too does he have dipped
i mean i couldn't tell
is he really it looks like 15 points or
something like that
which is again that's one of those
things that like
gross well it's growing whatever it's
you five
gross habits you're free to do whatever
you want but there's things you don't do
on the air
like you're actually better off smoking
on the air
because that at least like you know you
kind of it kind of conjures images of
like
carson back in the day when he had a big
old ashtray on his desk and it was like
you know uh tom snyder and like all
these guys that just were like
hey how you doing there jack good to see
you
you know but like because you could sit
there and be like hey boys
how's everybody doing it looks kind of
cool but when you're just like
hi money yeah and i'm doing uh i'm i'm
do
this is literally what it looks like hi
i only have to be on the air one hour a
day i'm hosting a talk show
that's what i hate the spitting but
anyway but what did you think last week
like a
box the box will look really
that's like not a habit that you want to
have on the air
it's almost like being out with a girl
right like
she could probably let it slide if you
smoke a cigarette but if you're just
sitting there going
so uh where'd you go to college and
you're just spitting in a cup they're
gonna be like this is the grossest [ __ ]
ever
the only time i find dip to be
acceptable is
if you are in the uh in the military
because they honestly don't even let you
smoke anymore like if you're if you're
deployed
they encourage you to use dip because
they don't want you to have lit
cigarettes at night
and potentially draw fire because if you
light a cigarette a
[ __ ] major heat signature it's easy
to spot
and then also if some snipers are out
there they just have to aim for that
cherry the cigarette blow your face off
so if you're in the military or if
you're just a hillbilly that picked up
the habit fine but if you're
hosting a talk show i think dip would be
the least
conducive for that oh yeah his brains
look good yeah but jeez
what's the thing um uh henry has that
piece of
dookie hanging on the back of his helmet
it's not no dookie that's dress
somebody on trevo also said if you play
baseball i will accept that i will
accept the baseball players
because to be honest i've seen some
baseball players without dip and i'm
like
this feels weird right like i feel like
they should all have dip in their mouths
uh no not right there oh no
um and then uh what's the other one the
mario lopez one
extra like that kind of stuff extra it's
it is what it is
it's mostly for women that have no lives
and they're like
oh i want to do that you know whatever
and
it's um that's fine
but but there's something super
about celebrity gossip about
athletes right like like sports talk is
bad enough but at least sports talk is
like
yeah man i don't know they're gonna have
to fix their pitching rotation this year
i don't know what the hell they were
thinking drafting this guy
i think the whole you know that that
kind of sports talk's fine but these
guys do the whole
yo check out his outfit dog yo his
outfit yo
yo you think he'd be like you think he'd
be getting mad [ __ ] bro
i wonder what kind of car he drives like
that's like a level of
where it's like you're combining sports
talk
and celebrity gossip
he also brought people in you mentioned
it earlier but
look at the way he's sitting he brought
people in to make himself look smart
like he really did and that's really
evident by look how he look how he's
sitting he's he's
he the thing with him and callum was
calling was obviously a real comedian
callum was actually funny you know he
could be funny
you know schaub is not so shop just
brought these two randos i don't know
who these guys are in
so they could so so then he has people
that are going to him like yeah hey shop
you're the man bro you're cool dude
you're the man dude you're cool
this is just an ecoboost show for him
now
is it is it like everywhere the why live
closer to here now so
i think it's here and there's also vista
yeah and downtown l.a
i'm not sure they got one uh right now
there's one calabasas
i don't know is it on la brea i'm trying
to skip ahead when they really get into
the
like into bits like into funny bits
i said come over here man over here
because i was coming over to pick up
some shoes and he's like yeah the gate
is over man just come around back
and i come around back sunday
he's that stereotypical black guy that
that mumbles a lot yeah it was like yeah
man it's like we were out there last
week you know uh
hanging out with my cousin you know even
coming up he's keep coming come on
go hey why why you all don't
say it like that yeah he talks like
trick daddy
you're like it's like you're at a drug
deal and you're really nervous
and you don't want to offend anybody
you're like
good stuff that was a great anecdote at
least there's not shoes on the table
man what's an addict though you calling
me
camo yeah and a hot tub is your sister
doing better now
yeah she's doing a lot after the trip
yeah we did that
no fees no surprises along the way more
confusion
your first month better times than mess
they're chilling better or
what do you mean they talked to about
everything going on maybe you got
anxiety maybe you got depression maybe
you just want to talk to somebody not
your friend
yeah you know what i did instead brendan
i don't know if you know this i know
better help is an option out there if
you guys want to pay
like 50 to 100 a month to talk to
somebody who doesn't even actually have
any degree
in psychology or you could do what i did
and pay like i don't know 50 bucks a
month and sign up online and talk to a
real doctor
who gives you drugs to help you with
those with those issues you have
i mean i get it if you want to just talk
to some [ __ ] college students
for for 10 minutes and pay money for
that but
what you get from better help you can
actually get
from a bartender except you could go to
a bar excuse me but let me ask you a
question
and get the same thing look at that face
and tell me you don't want to buy
take advice from that guy look at him
look i want you to really look at this
guy well yeah not him
but even the people on betterhelp it's
they're all like students of psychiatry
that don't have a degree yet and you're
just going to talk about your feelings
and then they can't even prescribe you
anything
so it's really silly to me when
basically better help is a bartender
without the booze
whereas at least if you go find a cool
bar with a cool bartender you can go in
there once a week have some drinks and
go
i just don't understand it man it's like
when i tell her something it just goes
in one ear and out the other
and then the bartender can go [ __ ] i
heard that man
and then you go anyway it felt really
good letting that off my chest
have a good weekend i'll see you next
week i was skipping ahead of the second
hour when they get really funny okay
the first hour they're feeling each
other out they're feeling each other out
usually she doesn't post shoes she
doesn't need neither one of them
is this whole show there's them looking
at people's instagrams this show
feels like i just met my weed dealer at
a diner and i'm waiting
for my weed and now i have to sit with
his friends
while he goes out to the car and gets
the weed and they're like yo order
something so it don't look so
i'll just get coffee then i guess and
then now you're sitting here with these
dudes that are like
shouting over each other about
basketball players sneakers and you're
like
i really gotta go i gotta go i gotta get
my stuff and
they do sit on each side of you so you
can't leave yeah joe it's like dog
you've seen that [ __ ] you seat that [ __ ]
bro and you're just going yeah man
that's
that's crazy my mommy left goes now this
should be qualified as chit chat
this is chit chat future but besides
future no one really
but on her story though not on her
dude yeah man rancid rules man but you
know what
i think operation ivy was better and
have him be like
man operation what who
brendan looks
so checked out because like you said
earlier and you nailed it
he misses brian callan's his friend
they're friends like you know their
friends doing a show their buddies they
know each other's timing they
they got it down they know to bust each
other's balls and now they
they're talking about future the rapper
and you think
[ __ ] job cares or knows about any of
that
he is just sitting there miserable
she's in place yeah she never made a
post no i don't know
[Laughter]
yep he never used to say that
no no no no no no he never used to say
dog he used to say b and stuff like that
papa
and papa but now he's he he's
he's around he's a chameleon he's oh my
god he's one of those guys man he's like
remember the old carson daly yeah
remember total request live carson daly
when he'd have like nsync or something
yeah
britney spears and he'd be like really
excited about your album tell us a
little bit about
like the process you went through when
you were making the eye and then ja rule
comes on
a jaw ruler somebody be like yeah dog yo
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] banging bro
oh god
still better than lily sing uh michael
jordan listen when you're when your mic
will be joined that's that's what that's
that's the get that's the lane you're in
man i mean yep that's the lane you're in
if they made it that official they're
getting married no they ain't nothing
wrong right like she's hot i'm gonna
skip ahead here she she is hot right but
just like
if royce came to me and said hey what if
we just did a segment every show
where we just ogled women on their
instagrams i'd be like
hey look man i like hot chicks and all
but is that good content like is that a
good show is
just gonna go yo yo check out them
titties yo
uh also they have a [ __ ] mulatto
frozen asian as their producer what is
that about
just like filipino [ __ ] yes
because he was accused of murder what
ended up happening was while he was in
jail
three weeks bef like three weeks into
his sentence
before he had to go to trial and get
sentence and all that he
i believe it was there was somebody who
was gonna snitch on him
and he wrote out this is our culture now
by the way
i want you to know this i really want
people to sit here and reflect on the
fact that
this is our culture now our culture it's
mainstream for people
to sit around and talk about who's
snitching
okay but now we're gonna go okay so
listen you know what it is you know what
they say about two hour shows
hour 15 is when it starts to pick up
so we're there we're at the hour 15 mark
we're about to kick it up to high gear
here we go
you ready your seat belt on because this
is recently right oh yeah
yeah oh they're still looking at
instagram i saw this this weekend
did you go to the website or the uh the
website oh okay
it'd be on there jim keep going that
dumb ass
how thick was busta rhymes
this is good conversations man i'm
skipping a little bit
born of a blessed career telling what
the kelly captioned the clip
thanks
[Music]
bro that's how i feel skipping through
your video fellas
mess with that no i mean the chick
brought me at a it was but this was a
whorehouse
can i say that can i say that
bro other dudes don't go there
he goes there this is
mike let me see that rule book can i
just throwing it out the window
can i just say that
brian callan was the one that was
accused
of things and brian callan ended up
better off
he did of course you did oh yeah i mean
the brian cowan allegations should be
the funniest thing in the world does
because it only hurt brenton shaw
it hurt him very much it hurt him a lot
and i've seen clips of callan show with
sam tripoli they are having a blast
they're having a lot of fun yeah they
got robbed
yeah that's all my money so dude banging
on the door get out
yeah like were you in there for a hot
second
i wasn't ever he look i obviously
it's been a while since we've watched
the show so maybe i've forgotten
but i'm just i think i'm really zoning
in on something here
is brendan chop talking more street now
yeah he's talking more street right he's
around the black guys
i mean i talk i always talk like myself
whether i'm on a black guy or a white i
don't i don't really
run in shops oh uh
excuse me ct brain damage yeah reach
out for five minutes and he said get out
yeah cause
cause okay so it was so weird it was
this thing this is back home in arizona
so it outside it looked like these were
these were chappelle two on
these these were 14 days
no this one that was 2 000 um six
oh oh six yeah i was 19. 06 in a
whorehouse mm-hmm
okay cause i was moving to texas and my
buddy was like all right you know what
they say
most shows saved the best for last so
i'm moving to the last 15 minutes
because we skipped through it
this makes me sad because at least the
brian cowan brandon chop show was fun to
pick apart because you know they were
doing things
this has been me skipping through a show
of absolute nothing of nothing
i would rather hear an act over here an
actual conversation at a diner
then this would be way more entertaining
than this
or do they have to make it even though
it goes against their morals if it's a
privately owned business it's tough
because social media right so it's
world like even though they're a private
company
their numbers say
what thank you that confused me no
that's reviews you do right
what what is that what it's a private
company but based on how much money they
make that's not
that doesn't change the fact that it's a
private company am i wrong
i mean i would say the fact that they're
in bed with the nsa and the government
and getting government preferential
treatment that would have been
that's okay well that's good but like
just
just you don't there's not like a cut
off it's not like
sorry sir you've made 250 million
dollars this year your company is no
longer private
media now like that's what a lot of
people are doing
they are the me that's where everyone
gets their media so
business-wise they might be a private
company but
usage-wise they're worldwide they're
international right so
the problem is but you could be a
worldwide private company
where you're located doesn't change
whether you're a private company uh
sorry royce i think i'm gonna defer to
the expert here
which one of these is the expert the
black guy in the rancid shirt
oh okay fair enough that if you went up
to him and said
yeah man i actually really really loved
uh and out come the wolves that was a
really great album
uh you like rancid and he would look at
you and go who the [ __ ] is rancid
can you be like your [ __ ] was on your
mind the one on the right's a black guy
trying to [ __ ] white women
the one on the left is a black guy that
likes dragon ball and the one in the
cereal is a [ __ ]
literal yeah this show's amazing i can't
wait
when these they're you know they're
super liberal so someone has a good
point these are three or
three 14 year olds sitting around
talking about nothing
this is like the this is the the group
of teenagers that sits in a restaurant
and no waiter wants to take it because
you know they're not going to tip
and they're going to be annoying and
they're that's what they are and they're
going to destroy the booth
oh yeah if they don't like a message
that it's going out they dictate what we
see and what we don't
you just can't have that man you just
can't you just can't have whether you
agree with a knight you can't have that
yeah it's cause where's it gonna stop so
the next
republican candidate if they don't like
the public take that out
it's like he's having a stroke all the
time
or for instance with corona stuff if you
didn't agree with what
their doctor said they got rid of it we
can't have them
also we're turning into north korea like
you're turning to communists and when
they falsely like when someone gets
falsely accused of something on
a social media outlet they don't take
that they don't take it down yeah
just leave it up how about how about how
about they ban
trump but then find mike pence and kill
him didn't get banned
it's terrible that they could pick and
choose all this that's not it's
what's the matter we used to watch
fighter and the kid right like
bryce allen and i honestly thought that
it couldn't get worse
i really thought i thought this dish
can't be anything worse after
all of 2020 yeah you're still going
around
saying things like it can't get no no no
i mean society and all that but i'm in
like a
show like a podcast well no that's my
point is that anything apparently can
get worse
not just society one thing society in
2020 has taught me is that
no matter how bad anything gets it could
always get
this this is worse because
it's utterly boring like so you know how
like there's
like bad movies like you like bad movies
like i like bad movies it's fun to sit
down and just watch a bad movie of
course but there's two different types
of bad movies there's bad movies that
are bad and they're funny because
they're bad
but there's movies that are just bad
where
it's not this is the old fighter and the
kid the brian callan incarnation of it
was
so bad that it was funny that redeeming
quality where we could goof on it was
funny
this is just bad this is just
just bad it's not they're not even
saying anything
it's dull this is dull which is the
worst thing like you know you're talking
about dsp
like dsp is [ __ ] a dumb [ __ ]
[ __ ] but he's funny because he's so
utterly incompetent there's that
redeeming
he's literally jerked off on stream like
he's so stupid there's that redeeming
quality of him
this is just they're just
boring which is the worst thing you
could be